[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Hi, this is Wesley
Chun, engineer at Google,
and happy to introduce you
to the Google Slides API.
It's new.
We've never had an
API for slides before.
Isn't that exciting?
With the API, developers
can write apps that create
or update slide presentations.
What does that really mean?
Well, there are so
many possibilities
I can only give you a few ideas.
An API means you can
take that data sitting
in a database or a
spreadsheet and make
it more visually appealing.
It also means that you can
have a core presentation
with placeholders
for text and images
and then customize it in
bulk for different customers.
But before I let you noodle
out some more great ideas out
of that genius brain
of yours, let's
show you how to
use the API first
so that when that brilliant
scheme washes over you,
you'll know exactly
how to make it happen.
In our demo, we'll have
just a title slide template,
like what you see here.
There are two placeholders--
one for the presentation name,
and the other, up
in the corner there,
is a rectangle where an image
will go, like a company logo.
In our example, we're going
to use a product icon.
Now, there are other
ways of getting images
into a presentation.
This is just one
of the techniques.
Both the icon and
the template files
are sitting pretty right in my
Google Drive folder right now.
If you've guessed that this
script uses both the Google
Drive and the
Google Slides APIs,
then you're right on target.
But before we get
to the code, go
to your project in
the Developers Console
to enable both the
Drive and Slides APIs,
then download the
JSON credentials file.
If you're new to developing,
using Google APIs,
be sure to check out our
earlier video walking you
through this process.
What's our script going to do?
Copy the slide template,
construct the request
to replace those placeholders
with a presentation name
and product icon, and
then call the Slides API
to execute those requests.
And then you'll end up with
your desired new presentation.
Now let's go to the computer
and look at the code.
Let's start with
lines one through 20.
This block of code includes
the standard imports
and boilerplate authorization
code that we're probably
already used to seeing.
Now, the things that
are different to take
note of in this script
include line seven and eight,
which are the file names for the
slide template and product icon
that are sitting in
our main Drive folder.
Lines 9 through 12 represent
the authorization scopes
to be able to copy
files in Google Drive,
plus have
[? read/write ?] access
to Google Slides presentations.
Now, this is the
first episode where
we're using more than one
Google API simultaneously.
So we should expect code to
look like this-- where you have
multiple scopes in the section.
Now, I choose to have multiple
strings-- each one representing
an individual scope.
But you could also
put all the scopes
in one giant string,
which are space delimited.
To me, this is easier to read.
Then, lines 18
through 20 are where
we're creating the
service endpoints
to the APIs using the same
[INAUDIBLE] HTTP client.
On lines 22 to 25 is where
we use the Google Drive
API to find the template
file and copy it,
saving the ID of the new
presentation that's created.
On lines 27 to 33 is
where we use the Slides
API to find that rectangle
placeholder where
the image will go.
Lines 35 to 39 are
where we use the Drive
API to find the image file
and get the secure URL.
Or it can be downloaded.
That's how the
Slides API creates
images and presentations.
All of the real work
is in lines 41 to 53,
where we're putting together our
set of requests for the Slides
API.
The first is replaceAllText,
where the presentation name
replaces the text placeholder
that we had in the template.
The second is createImage to
replace the image placeholder
with a product icon using
that secure URL we just
talked about.
Remember earlier how we
grabbed that rectangle
where the image will go?
You know, the placeholder?
Well, we use its dimensions
so that the product
icon is re-sized and drops
right over that rectangle
placeholder.
Finally, the last
request is deleteObject,
because once we have our
product icon in place,
we don't need that image
placeholder anymore.
And the last lines of
code down at the bottom
are where we send all of
these requests to the API
and then let the
user know we're done.
Let's run this script, which
we call slides_template.
Now, you can use
Python 2.0 or 3.0.
It doesn't really matter
because this script
works with both versions
without any additional code.
Assume that we've run our
[INAUDIBLE] authorization flow
and accepted the request.
And you can see the output
from the print calls
until it's finished.
And now all you need
to do is confirm
that the new deck exists
in your Drive folder
with all the substitutions.
And if you click on the New
Presentation in Google Drive,
you should have something
that looks like this.
Now you have an idea of what
the Google Slides API can do
in less than 60 lines of code.
If you want a deeper dive
in today's code sample,
check out the blog post.
If you want to start
with an easier example,
check out the quickstart,
which is available in Python
in other languages.
If you're ready to wrap
your head around how
the API works in general,
check out the first link.
To see the JSON payloads
for common operations
you perform with the API,
go to the second link.
And to go straight to
the API reference docs,
hit up the third link.
The next step is up to you.
It's a green field out there.
The Google Slides API is just
waiting for your next big idea.
Go out and build
that awesome app.
And be sure to subscribe
to our channel,
and tune in again next time.
This is Wesley Chun from
Google, and we'll see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]